[Music]
oh there they are
ladies and gentlemen the bride and groom
to be emily and
marcus
what the hell is that you son of a
you said we were best friends
yeah it's like up what are you
two doing here
excuse me this is a private event oh
it's cool we know the bride and groom
we met these two animals down in mexico
why does the salt not taste salty oh
because it's cocaine what
we actually brought it from home very
very easy if you ever want to try it
it's just a ziploc and a full shampoo
bottle
and it's so much more comfortable than i
had it in my ass hmm
okay look we just got a container this
only happened because
you said see you later i said it without
meaning it like any decent person would
and somehow he's charming my dad hope
you're comfortable and enforcing oh is
there's at least one girl involved
this weekend is all about you well i
like the sound of that
we do too jesus good evening everyone
what is he doing
marcus and i crossed paths in mexico get
to know each other
intimately this is the best wedding i've
ever been to
put that bottle on your head babe he's
not serious we've been drinking it
count it you hit the bottle this time
what
jackpot the devil's dick most potent
magic mushroom on earth
i ate it why you told me to i didn't say
eat it man
everything you touch turned into drugs